la légion romaine en pleine action nous
sommes sur la rive nord de la loire sur
le site de l'abbaye de marmoutier qui
fut en son temps celle de saint martin
de tours elle est aujourd'hui le siège
d'une grande reconstitution historique
consacré à la période gallo romaine une
première c'est une période qui n'est pas
si lointaine que ça parce que nous
sommes les héritiers à la fois des
romains des gaulois et déjà main et le
site de marmoutier nous il est
emblématique c'est un site qui est
original ce n'est marche et originale
inédite en région centre et à tour donc
tout c'était l'occasion de travailler
sur une période jamais exploité
finalement dans sur nos territoires ici
soldats romains guerrier germain ou
valeureux gaulois ne sont pas venus pour
faire de la figuration
tous sont des passionnés comme ce
professeur d'histoire lui aussi tombé
dans la marmite lorsqu'il était plus
petit moi je suis très attaché à cette
notion de l'histoire vivante parce qu'on
essaie d'être au plus proche de la
réalité historique avec modestie parce
que des choses qui est qui nous échappe
mais qu'on peut essayer d'approcher par
l'expérimentation et c'est aussi un
aspect de médiation j'ai cette passion
de l'histoire et je veux la vivre de son
intérieur est bien comprendre parce que
la plus grosse difficulté c'est de se
mettre dans un personnage de l'antiquité
ils sont complètement différents de nous
aujourd'hui
très différent également les membres de
cette tribu gauloise outils artisanat
alimentation on découvre tout de leur
usage d'époque et là encore on se
transmet les gestes avec le plus grand
sérieux c'est en train d'apprendre à
forger un petit couteau je me suis fort
gens ici qui me qui m'aide à me
perfectionner dans la forme d'un couteau
gaulois premier siècle avant des
reconstitutions particulièrement soignée
donc et le public plébiscite j'aime bien
me sens comme moi fin mai au moins et du
coup bah c'est pour d'être ici c'est
très intéressant de voir cette
reconstitution faites par des
spécialistes
un public contre est venu en nombre
durant tout le week end du coup il se
pourrait bien que cette première édition
devienne pérenne et se reproduisent
chaque fin d'été par toutatis
[Musique]